Are you one of those guys that keeps
finding themselves where you keep
getting stop loss hit just to see price
go in the direction you originally
planned for?
Then this video is for you, all right?
So, look at this wick. This is Bitcoin
June 10th. Price just dumps straight
through 61k.
Rips out every stop sitting under those
lows, taps 61 and a half, and then turns
around and runs through basically 3
grand higher, right?
And here's the thing. I was long through
this entire wick.
Same entry as everybody who entered
around the golden fibs.
Same fib level, same level, same idea,
right? The only difference was where my
stop was. So, let me show you why their
stop was sitting below this low
and mine was here.
So, quick context on this trade, right?
We sold off hard from the highs.
This is the value area high, the point
of control, and the value area low of
these this entire range.
And I'm looking at the 618 of this
entire swing low to swing high,
which sits perfectly at the value area
low. Okay?
Now, how does basically everyone take
this trade, right?
Long at the fib, stops just below the
level.
That's the rule that we all got taught
in the trading, right?
The problem is that everyone looking at
the same fib
has the same stops essentially.
So, let's reframe this and honestly how
this one kind of just changes and clicks
everything, okay?
The second
your stop loss is
hit, it's not protection. Your stop loss
is a resting market order, okay? The
second it gets touched,
it market sells into the market
instantly.
It doesn't ask, "Hey, is this wick
fake?" right?
It just It just sells.
So, all those dots,
all the liquidity, all the heat maps
that you have on your chart that you see
at most of wicks.
The second it gets touched, right?
Just sitting there in the open.
It's just waiting for somebody big
enough to come and take them, okay?
Now, before anyone basically says this,
um
you know, and there's a lot of
conspiracy on this. No, there's there's
really not some guy
and some, you know, big corporate tower
hunting, you know, your $400 long or
whatever your size is, you know.
You're not that important. I'm not that
important. But, here's what's actually
going on, right? Say a fund wants to buy
real size down here.
What they need is sellers. They can't
just market buy. They'd push price up
against their own fills.
A ton of sellers is what they need all
at once at the lows. So, where do you
find thousands of guaranteed sellers at
the lows? Yeah, basically right here.
Below these lows.
Below the value area low. Below the
auction, right?
So,
every single stop under that level
is someone who has to sell the moment
price touches it because that's where
their stops are. So, the play basically
writes itself. Push price through 61,
boom, first wave of stops fires for
selling everywhere, right? Pushes
through the value area low, reclaims,
second wave, and the whole way down
someone's just sitting on the bid eating
every single one of these forced
sellers, right? Now, I entered early at
the 618, but I gave myself enough room
at the stop loss.
We came all the way back up, reclaimed
the point of control, tapped weekly
naked point of control, came back down
where everybody's stops would be, right?
At the assumed lows. And what if I had
done that, I would have been stopped
out, okay?
But, I let it breathe, okay?
Now,
this is the key, okay?
This is how you see it coming. And
here's the thing, this sweep isn't a
surprise, right? This whole trade has
been planned,
um you know, since we even formed this
high, right?
You have your value area low.
It's been tapped once, twice, almost
three times, right? And every single
time it's it's held. So, more longs pile
in and every long put under, you know,
puts another stop underneath it, right?
So, old levels don't get safer the way
they hold, they get heavier, right? So,
this first one, people take this long
and then they start putting their stops
here, here, here, here, here, here,
right?
And that's thin volume underneath. Price
moves faster thin volume. And that's
exactly why this wick looks so violent
and scary when you zoom in, right?
People are long that 15 the 5-minute the
1-minute and um
you know, the shape of that wick was
basically written in the volume profile
before it even happened. And we can go
ahead and look at that, right?
So, let's go ahead and look at the
volume profile and we'll switch over to
this.
Now, this is the same exact
chart that you were just looking at, but
this is footprint. This is order flow,
okay?
Now, this is the 4-hour.
So, I'm just condensing all the volume
that happened in this 4-hour. You were
just looking at the 15-minute on
TradingView. This is a toss. This is the
4-hour, okay?
Now, I had my entry here, basically
right here, okay?
We came up and tapped the previous week
point of control up here.
We came back down and took out the
people who longed here with me
and then placed their stops at the low
here. And they what? Got stopped out.
Now, the real real
telling point here,
right?
is the order flow, the footprint,
okay?
You can see the absorption in this
single 4-hour candle and you can
probably spot it where it's at.
Well, if we look at Delta on this candle
here,
you have -17
million Delta.
Okay?
You have 14 million, and you can't
really see it, so I'll have to zoom in
here. 14 million in shorts opening. At
the same time, you have 3 million, 3
million, 5 million, 3 million, 2
million, 2 million, and 4 million in a
longs opening at the same time. You got
a lot of shorts opening, and again,
all right? Visualize this here. We'll go
back to TradingView.
Do you see the difference? Do you see
where that that 4 million sits at?
You see the overlay?
That's the value area low, the golden
pocket. That's exactly where people put
their put their stops, right down here.
So, you have massive, massive
selling aggression into
pretty good support.
But, it's not going anywhere, and what
did we do?
We had a very nice
high aggressive
immediate follow-up of buyers. 9 million
in positive Delta that pushed price
right up into it. So, you had a lot of
selling aggression and shorts piling in
at support,
but they didn't actually push it and
have successful time pushing it past
support because buyers showed up.
Someone with a big market order ate up
those sellers, and then pushed price up
insanely well. Buyers defended that
level, right? And you can clearly see
that. You don't even need order flow to
see it. You can see it right here. Okay?
It's the same thing at every single
level.
And that's not even the major low. This
is just a very high level. Now, you
could also layer on, if you have other
things, you know, this level also had a
daily naked point of control here, a
weekly naked point of control here, and
a daily open here. So, you had three
other confluences that's not on this
chart at the time cuz I've already
deleted them, but you have a lot of
confluence right there, okay?
So,
here's the payoff
and the four rules and how you can see
every single one basically, right? So,
rule one,
your stop goes beyond the sweep zone,
right?
Mine was under 59.23.
Um you know, basically just kind of
sitting here. Um excuse me. 60.6, right?
Actually, yeah, no, it's sitting here at
59.8, right?
And that's just under the golden pocket
because the question isn't where does my
idea get uncomfortable,
you know, it's if they sweep this, where
does it run out of gas, okay?
Put the stops past that. You know, they
don't run out of gas if they go past
here. If price comes down here, okay?
If price does this and comes down here,
well, it's very likely that these lows
are going to get swept and we're going
to continue lower. So, my invalidation
is here.
They don't run out of gas right here,
obviously, cuz that's still support.
Okay? So, that's rule number one. Rule
number two,
I know what you're thinking, right? Bro,
dude, just stop. This isn't even $1,100
away. Like I can't risk that, right? So,
so don't. People People are saying,
"Dude, you can't have such a wide stop."
You especially like funded traders. You
I can't have such a wide stop.
And
here's the thing, you're right.
But cut your size in half. Your risk is
size times the difference, right? Double
the stop, half the size, you're going to
win a lot more trades. Rule number
three, invalidate on structure, not on
touch, right? Now, market structure
here, if you want to assume a higher low
bounds in the larger context of this,
like we have, you knew that after
aggressive selling, you'd probably
continue to see at least a retrace back
up to that larger value, which is what
we're working on right now.
Okay?
And rule number four,
at some point, flip the whole thing,
right?
Just flip it.
Once you can see the liquidity pool, why
are you only avoiding it? Let them run
the lows. Watch the absorption on the
footprint, right?
And enter on the reclaim. You don't even
have to enter in early like I did, okay?
I entered in here.
You could have waited for here. Wait for
that low to be swept. Wait for the value
area low. Wait for the liquidity to be
taken again. And then place your stops
here and you get a short at tight tight
stop loss, right?
So,
let's just kind of again,
re- re- re-cap on everything that we
looked at because, you know, I've taken
the time to just really talk through
this very slowly, very simply, because
there's really not a whole lot going in
here, right? You take a fixed range
volume profile
on this whole range. Get your value area
low, your point of control, your value
area high.
Here's our low.
Here's our high. We rotated through
value. We came down and took out all the
liquidity that was basically built up in
these levels.
We have the 618 and the 66, which again
is just pulling from lows to highs.
And then, you know, we have liquidity
that was grabbed. And then now we're
making way for liquidity that was pulled
here, right?
So, at the end of the day,
now simply I am up
4% unrealized, right? I've already taken
profits at the weekly open.
But now I you know, I can move stops to
break even and now I have to worry about
this trade into winning trade. And I can
look for higher prices if that's where
we're going.
So, I hope this video helped you because
it's all about where your stop loss is
and not really your entry. Obviously,
you got to get a pretty good entry and
you got to understand where your entry
should be.
But you don't have to really nail down a
good entry. You still could have even
longed here, right? And then had some
breathing room down here. And you still
could have had a good trade. Would I say
that's an A+ setup? No, but you're going
to want to long at support and look for
resistance and short at resistance,
right? Buy low, sell high. That's really
what we're doing here. And you just got
to give yourself a little bit of room, a
little bit of the biggest thing is where
do sellers run out of gas? Well, it's
probably around this liquidity zone. You
know, I gave myself a little bit of room
down here.
Cuz obviously if you come down here,
you're likely going to run these lows
and come down to make, you know, point
of controls, monthly point of controls,
weekly point of controls, anything that
acts as a magnet, right?
So, I hope you guys enjoyed this. Smash
like if you did, and we'll see you in
the Discord.